hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
monday monday monday
april 19 2021
what's going on how are you i don't know
what just happened with that monday
i started doing it i started thinking of
robert plant and he's like john bonham
over the top top top top dot
like that was like some crazy effect
that you could have back in the 1970s
and people back when lsd was the real
[ __ ]
man none of these [ __ ] happy
mushrooms i figured myself out man
this was the real [ __ ]
the [ __ ] that made you think you could
fly and you'd rip your eyeballs out or
whatever else they used to tell you in
those stupid
student films which evidently was all
[ __ ]
i never did acid you have drop acid
uh why would i do that kind of sounds
like i wouldn't want to do that to my
brain
ah dude i [ __ ] dropped acid back in
at a steve miller concert oh
the second he went into uh
tick tock tick dude i went back in time
and then what happened i got a job at
home depot
i was one of the three people that they
hired at one of their locations
i am convinced that they they have a
minimum of six employees at each
home depot you know
i bet there's a lot of like struggling
actors that work at home depot
and then they say they go like oh is
this what fame is like
i don't want to do this like you know
when you're going to home depot it's
just like if there's anybody with one of
those [ __ ]
aprons on like 40 people like oh my god
where the [ __ ] is the thing
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me
doing that as they're trying to talk to
you
and then you're the person like i found
them first
get away from me get away from me right
like the [ __ ] i don't know i [ __ ]
hate that place
home depot is the [ __ ] worst
you know what you really need to do if
you're going to shop at home depot
you got to spend a week there by
yourself and you yourself have to figure
out where the [ __ ] everything is so when
you go in there
you know what the [ __ ] going on
because if you want help in that [ __ ]
[ __ ] of a place
just giant you know what makes you feel
more lonely in that place is how high
the ceilings are
hello hello hello yeah yeah
yeah looking for a casket
gasket [ __ ] worst um
so anyway i had a i had a freaking great
i had a great day a great day yesterday
um i was uh first of all it was the
perfect day out here and i was just
thinking wouldn't it be great if every
day was like this
then i realized if every day was like
that then it'd just be like
you know you'd get bored
you'd be praying for an earthquake or uh
or a rainstorm which is why
heaven the concept of heaven has never
made sense to me just every day
is just [ __ ] amazing every forever
you just walk around happy all the time
there's
the way human beings are your brain
would just level off
you know like when you're in them clouds
you don't know which way you're going
your equilibrium tells you up right when
you ain't
right you would be sitting there just
thinking like
after a while like you know in this gray
it's great yeah it's great it's [ __ ]
heavy it's amazing [ __ ] month in
ah and i tell you it's every day
every day it's gonna be like this
everybody's gonna have their eyebrows up
just walking around like oh my god this
is so [ __ ] great
um geez that's a scary thought because
the whole concept then when you start
thinking about that the whole concept of
forever
is just like it just
it it seems worse than this [ __ ] because
no matter what the [ __ ] you're going
through in this life it's gonna end
at least it's gonna there is an ending
to the movie
don't take that ending um
hardcore mash fans know why i just sang
that theme song
um you know that there's a [ __ ]
ending
um but with that [ __ ] there's like no
but then if you went to hell oh you're
going to burn me again well you know
yeah hell well hell for some reason the
hell i can picture that better
i don't know what that says about me i
can picture just being tortured for the
rest
forever i don't know i just can't
imagine
just [ __ ] hanging out you know i'll
say what you want about hell i bet
there's a lot of funny bastards down
there
um making fun of the way you scream when
you're in fire versus them
the ball breaking would start and then
the devil will get mad hey i said no fun
down here
oh dad's home [ __ ]
what are you gonna do send me to hell
again you [ __ ] red [ __ ]
um
hey man like why can't we all just sort
of you know clean up down here and just
realize we all [ __ ] up
on earth and uh let's just make the best
out of it
can you imagine that can you imagine if
you unionized health down there and
everybody just thought all right
i don't know but then you'd have like
rapists and [ __ ] pedophiles down
there you'd have to watch out for
that's a stupid idea that'd be like if
you could somehow get everybody
in a jail if you were in prison to all
of a sudden just be cool to each other
make everything else go away you can't
[ __ ] do it i'd be like again the
middle east everybody to settle down
maybe like getting the corporations to
actually do something right for the
people rather than their own
[ __ ] wallet and be like the nfl
taking responsibility for the health of
the player
sorry anyway i was trying to say it was
a great day i
i uh i went flying yesterday with my
my instructor and um it was windy of
[ __ ]
and like 30 knot wins and he's like
we'll be all right we'll be all right so
30 knot wins
i uh i was actually faced the wrong way
it was weird one windsock was blowing
one way one was blowing the other
and the flag i usually look look at was
not
they didn't have it up the pole that day
so i was like all right well we usually
go this way
and of course i get in you know
i get in i turn on the [ __ ] radios i
listen to the adis and it says they're
going the other way and i'm like all
right well
what are you gonna do lifted that [ __ ]
up nice and straight
slid out went the other way and came
around and the [ __ ]
you know when i took off obviously into
the wind it wasn't bad but it was still
bumpy
but when i went crosswind and then went
downwind and the wind was to my
back um yeah that was pretty uh
it was pretty intense it's pretty
[ __ ] intense
and uh the whole day was really bumpy
but the great day great thing about
flying in that other than the experience
of it
is uh la is so [ __ ] clear
on those days like um usually on days
when it's good to fly
just the haze that's out there everybody
always thinks people mistake
smog and haze smog is brown haze is haze
everybody just because of la's
reputation just thinks every day like
the air quality out here is way better
than it was back in the 70s and 80s when
it was just like [ __ ] brown
outside so um
but on yeah it's just all the people
driving around the dust and all the
literally like i might even get into
where i realize what haze is it's also
like [ __ ]
yeah all the people out here your skin
flakes off that gets in the air it's
[ __ ] disgusting what it really is so
anyway
mother nature blows it all out at least
that's what i heard that might be wrong
i don't know
mother nature blows all of that [ __ ] out
right
and uh yeah it's just dust dirt [ __ ]
all of that [ __ ]
the same [ __ ] that's in your house just
goes up into the air so it's blown all
the way those are the days when they
take
you know they hire helicopters and then
they do the touristy pictures
of los angeles and those are the days
when you can see downtown l.a and behind
it you see snow-capped mountains and
you're like
how did they take downtown l.a and drop
it in the middle of [ __ ] utah what is
this right
it's those days that they do it so we
flew um
i did an instrument approach into uh
santa monica and then i transitioned
along the beach through la airspace at
or below 150 which is the [ __ ] i'm gonna
film that one day for you guys just to
see what that's like on a beach day
there's people on surfboards [ __ ]
doing the waving you know crossing the
arms over the head doing the
like come rescue me [ __ ] um you got to
look out for kites
that's how low you are um and then you
get on the other side the smoke stacks
you come up you get on with torrents
we did uh some landings there on the uh
the pad and uh
then we flew up near hawthorne i got to
see you know a little bit of the rams
san diego chargers new stadium which
looks just
[ __ ] incredible looks like a stingray
that's like been was swimming and they
took a picture when it was flapping down
it's [ __ ] amazing
um but that is in the bravo airspace if
you guys are into this [ __ ]
where are all the big guys all the big
boys land and ladies and they's
all right [ __ ] [ __ ] before we try
to get me in trouble
um they all come in so you go around
that
and go up to 110 and uh
it was so [ __ ] by the time we got
back the airport that i flew out of the
wind gusts were up to 50 knots
and we were like you know what [ __ ] that
and i learned a really cool thing you
just call another airport
which i guess i would have figured out
if i was soloing but this is why i
always still go with an instructor to
keep learning on these new experiences
we just sat down at another airport
ubered back to the airport we took off
from you know i'm just paying the fee to
leave it there overnight and after my
podcast i'm gonna go over today's a nice
calm day get up fly it
put it on the dolly and stick it back in
the little [ __ ] hanger
uh but it was fun as hell to get back up
there
and um i hadn't flown in a little over a
week
i got some work coming up uh we're
editing um
season five episode family and i just
got a little busy doing that so
whenever i don't fly for more than like
four or five days i always end up just
going up with an instructor and gonna be
like all right let's go through this you
know do some auto rotations
and uh you gotta be humble man
you can't be thinking you [ __ ] know
everything but uh
i had a great time and listen to this
[ __ ] so i've been listening to a lot of
um
i always was fascinated
about the uh the whole session musician
studio musician scene that existed out
here in la
and hearing stories about how you know i
was talking to a guy yesterday who was
going oh man he goes i would have two or
three sessions a day
and then some guys were so good and
needed so much
that they had an open call to drop into
these places
to do jingles for like commercials for
radio or for tv
they just had an open [ __ ] call
um you know one of these days uh when
when this [ __ ] thing clears up
vinnie collieudo one of the greatest
drummers of all time i'm gonna try to
get him on my podcast so he can talk
about
i talked to him about it one time where
he was he was the drummer for the joan
rivers show
he was doing all these sessions and had
jingles and also
tord and he just was just constantly
playing drums and i just downloaded this
[ __ ] album that he played on
which is really incredible because i
know that i heard this music
before some sort of sports highlights or
um
or possibly the olympics i don't know if
anybody recognizes this music here
it's not something i would normally
listen to but i was listening to
let's see here let me just sort of fast
forward through this part
let me see if i get to the beginning of
this thing here we go
wait
[Music]
and the kansas city royals have turned a
corner
winning six of the last seven thanks to
willie wilson
the better frank white and their closer
dennis leonard
right so it's like that type of [ __ ] so
this album
is crazy as that [ __ ] is like if you
this bill mayers or myers
m-e-y-e-r-s it's called images you can
get it on
uh itunes and what's cool about this
thing
is they had these things back then these
recordings it was straight to disk
and what you had you had to record i
don't know if i talked about this last
podcast
i can't remember you had to record the
whole [ __ ] album in one take
and if anybody [ __ ] anytime anybody
[ __ ] up they had to start over again
on the first [ __ ] song
so you know if you were gonna [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up in the very beginning don't [ __ ]
up on track number eight
out of 10 or whatever um so this album
if you listen to it
um and you listen to the arrangements
the different time signatures
and uh sometimes when the whole band
drops out and and
the uh the keyboards are just playing
the hits they're always like
offbeats and just really crazy [ __ ]
and vinnie is just the whole band is
just [ __ ] on it so anyways there was
that whole
scene back then so i of course love
drums and everything so
i was watched this great video that my
drum teacher uh dave elich
sent me on uh jeff picaro and he
mentioned all of these guys most of
the guys i heard of andy newmark vinnie
and those guys but uh there's always
this guy jim gordon
that i always heard about there was this
incredible [ __ ] drummer
unfortunately was an undiagnosed
schizophrenic and uh
heard voices and killed his mom himself
that's the other side but but when he
was behind the drums
um anyway um so
they he was talking jeff picard was
talking about some of the albums that
they played on so i looked up i don't
know how
i ended up list getting into like this
carly simon right
not this carl it's carly simon album so
i got the one that had the hit you're so
vain
on it and um that has jim gordon playing
drums and his
you know incredible track that he plays
on and first of all the lyrics to you're
so vain
you know i remember when i was growing
up i wasn't growing up i was
i was like i don't know my early 20s
when that [ __ ] um or maybe late
twenties i don't know when it came that
jagged little pill
once her face came out what she's just
like
say ha ha i [ __ ] hate you
step on your nut sack that [ __ ] son
mr duplicity let's see
and everybody's just like oh [ __ ] she
went in she [ __ ] went
in right which she did
and it was way different than anything
out there but i gotta remember she went
in so [ __ ] hard
and she showed tapped in to how jilted
and left behind she felt that as a man
when i listened to it
i was just like i don't know who she's
singing about but i hope i'm glad he is
not near her
i felt it's funny women listen to it and
we're just like
yeah [ __ ] that's what you [ __ ] get
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me and leave me and
[ __ ] read a song about you
all i would think was like jesus christ
if this guy's dick is still attached to
his body good on him
that's all i got out of that but if you
listen to the carly simon you're so vain
which by the way by the way mick jagger
is singing back up
from the second chorus on and what's so
crazy about it
is is like
you i've never heard all these years
i've heard that song i never heard his
voice and then once you know he's
singing back up
it's so up in the mix you can't not
[ __ ] hear it
and he's even like totally singing like
mick
i bet you think this song is a bat yeah
you know
yeah right i know i'm doing bad you can
almost feel like his [ __ ] hand on his
hip when he's doing the [ __ ] right
so uh but anyway the the
lyrics to that one is as
hard as she's going in i guess it's
about each verse is about a different
guy
that uh she had dated and
um because everyone's like oh that
song's about this guy that song's about
this guy
oh no it's about that guy or whatever
but she's now starting to say who the
song is about
um which to me indicates she that has a
book or a tour coming up because why
would you do it after all of these years
um you know it's all it's all a [ __ ]
it's all ringling brothers it's like
that fight this weekend
well that that [ __ ] that was going on
all of that
that [ __ ] donnie and marie show meets
[ __ ]
boxing whatever the [ __ ] that's supposed
to be
um i actually got two invites to watch
that you say you know watch that it's
like no no i'm not
i don't want to see the wedding band
version of boxing i just don't
but i'm happy for everybody
you know that went in and fought and
made some [ __ ] money you know what i
mean but i'm not paying the same amount
of money
that i paid to see professional fighters
to see this [ __ ] and then see somebody
win
and you start thumping your chest like
you're the second coming of [ __ ] roy
jones um
and my favorite thing is standing up on
the ropes thumping your chest like
you're like there's a crowd there
uh
i didn't even but this is this is me
okay i didn't even rent conor mcgregor
versus floyd mayweather that was the
dumbest [ __ ] thing i'd ever seen in
my life
this guy is one of the greatest boxers
of all time this guy's one of the great
mixed martial arts fighters of all time
so we are going to try to determine
who is the best fighter by fighting to
one of their strengths
it's just like if they fought and it was
like all right we're gonna go into the
octagon
what's his face mcgregor ends
floyd mayweather in the first [ __ ]
minute
that's it he's in an armbar he chokes
him he just takes it to the ground it's
[ __ ] over
they're just gonna stand there and fight
i mean how did you not see that coming
all right floyd could take this guy out
in
under a [ __ ] minute but instead
he's gonna carry him so people feel like
they got their money's worth before he
finally takes them out it's it's [ __ ]
um
look i'm not gonna say it's ridiculous
it's entertainment that's all it is it's
[ __ ] entertainment but uh
yeah i wasn't gonna sit there and watch
that [ __ ] uh but i will talk about it to
give it more attention
which is what everybody [ __ ] needs so
it continues on
all right but my buddy pete davidson did
host it so i was happy for him
and i saw that he was trending and
everybody said he was absolutely [ __ ]
hilarious and then that made me wish
that i did rent it so who knows but you
know what i didn't watch it because
i was too busy um watching
my boston bruins with the taylor hall
trade which all of a sudden has injected
the life that we needed in our offense
okay and we sweep the islanders who we
could not
beat well we beat them back-to-back
games i can't say that's a sweep you
need that you need it's a three-game
suite
you know a home and home whatever the
[ __ ] you call those things uh we beat
him both games
and then we beat the capitals and scored
like [ __ ] six goals
on them i missed yesterday's game but
like you know
the caps kind of like the best we could
do we or we'd always be up two to one in
the third period
then they tie it and then we would lose
in a shootout and they well you know you
got a point out of it it's like well you
know i think in the playoffs that's a
[ __ ] loss
so i don't see us doing well against
them so um i feel like
we have risen up to the level of those
two teams at least so
now we can compete if you're gonna get
out there every week
i need to know that you're gonna compete
and do the things you need to do
um so i'm very happy about that man that
makes me feel uh
you know makes me feel good and you know
what i went on the [ __ ] internet i
already forget this guy's name
but somehow in my youtube you know when
when you go on and and it has you it
tries to suggest videos for you to watch
this this [ __ ] bruin that i had never
heard of
see let me just i can look him up 1978
bruin ot goal
canadians
um bobby schmatz
he just passed away he dies at 76.
um when the hell was that
i guess it was uh earlier this year so
rest in peace to him
um i had never i didn't know that this
is the guy
that that character dr hook was based on
in slap shot the guy was like my size
he fought like the [ __ ] tasmanian
devil
and he had no [ __ ] problem
taking his stick and going right for
your eye and he didn't even give a [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] lunatic
[ __ ] lunatic um be honest with you
i've never liked players like that
i just you know you know if you want to
be a [ __ ] lunatic and do whatever it
takes
i i i draw the line at trying
not caring if you don't end somebody's
career but um
he seemed like uh like
when you read about this guy in the way
he played i watched this video
of him it was like you it was like one
of those wild west characters
john wesley harden so mean he once shot
a man for snoring too loud like he was
just like
he was out of those days except he was
on skates
and had a stick um
all of that stuff's really fascinating
so then of course then i go down a
rabbit hole
and um if you want to learn about
players in back then uh the
one of the greatest things to do is you
just go buy a complete set
of cards so i find you know i was
looking at like hockey cards and that
type of [ __ ] and just the
[ __ ] names it's like every name was
just off
let me see if i still have it up here um
i don't know if i i think i got rid of
it yeah i did i had it on ebay like i
was looking at the early 70s
every guy's name jacques claude jean
like they were all frenchmen
um and everybody was like canadian and
there was only a couple of americans
and uh you know it took me the longest i
didn't even realize that when i
just thought anybody from with an
english-sounding name
was from the united states and it really
was just english-speaking canada
which is basically everything west of
montreal as far as i know
and um it was kind of fascinating to
watch that and he also i think he had
stan jonathan's number
first and then stan jonathan had it and
then nevin marquat
and uh forget who had it after that
what was lou cheech was lou cheats 17 i
can't even remember anymore
lucich number four bruins
he was 17. yeah yeah so there's
something about that number if you get
that number for the bruins
that you are going to be a lunatic at
the very least like
you know you're going to be somebody
you're going to be a force to be
reckoned with
um so anyway
uh red sox seem to keep winning
um i watched actually a full game of
theirs the other day it's a fun team
and uh i think i'm gonna get the mlb
package
give me something to do this summer as i
wait for stuff to start opening up so i
can get out there and start touring
again i cannot wait
this is how much my brain is in stand up
right now i actually
woke up thinking of a bit
you know well you know what it had to do
it had to do with me thinking about
getting this [ __ ] f250
this ford truck that i always wanted
which i don't [ __ ] need
and i really don't have any space i
don't have any space for people i'd have
to put it in [ __ ] storage and switch
it in and out like
what am i doing do i really want to do
that yes
um but i will give you
i will tell you this this is what i've
learned with building a car
on the internet all right
i don't give a [ __ ] what it looks like
whatever the color is you go down and
you look at it
go down and look at that [ __ ] and see
what color it really is
because i built this ford f250
4x4 sprayed in liner
the diesel engine and i did it in
velocity blue
and it was the most gorgeous truck i had
seen in the modern era
it looked like this aqua sort of misty
blue
understated but classy
almost looking like that cadillac blue
that i loved
that caddy in that tarantino movie uh
once upon a time in hollywood
when they pull up to the sharon tate
house i mean that [ __ ] eldorado
is god that [ __ ] car
oh my god and the thing about that car
it's so beautiful
i wouldn't want my friend to have it so
i could drive next to it
and just watch it go down the road
because that's the thing when you're
driving the beautiful car you don't get
to see it
you get to drive it but you don't get to
see it so
um anyway so i went down to look
to see what this velocity blue looks
like cause a buddy
of mine who just ordered a truck and and
uh he got in he said this is this is
what the color looks like and i was
looking at going that's a lot more bluer
than i thought
dude i saw that in the sunlight dude it
is it's like smurf blue
like a play-doh blue it's just like god
damn that's [ __ ] blue
and they have a big truck in that color
i was just like no [ __ ] way
so now i'm back to the drawing board
with that [ __ ]
and that's kind of like what i was
thinking about
um as i'm kind of going back and forth
on whether to do something stupid like
that
um
that's what gave me the idea for the bit
which i'm not gonna tell you because i
need [ __ ]
for my act so anyway so last night after
we set the helicopter down and
everything
and uh ubered back got in our cars
laughed and [ __ ]
went our separate ways came home had a
great dinner
you know and all of that [ __ ] and then
you know it was
uh it was the weekend so that's when i
get crazy
you know that's when i really throw down
and i go out and get myself a chocolate
malt
i switched it up i got an oreo shake
got one for me and one for my wife and i
was driving and it was the perfect
[ __ ] night that's what i was getting
to
it was just the perfect temperature and
that breeze that was [ __ ] with us
when we were flying
on the ground was [ __ ] amazing um
had the windows down and there was no
traffic out and it was really quiet for
whatever reason
and um you know it's not often
that you get the great feeling of of
driving in the middle of nowhere
um on a great road in los angeles in a
city you don't get that feeling too
often but uh
you know i i
i don't know it was just it really was
just a perfect night and then the
[ __ ] shake was delicious
and that's that's what i do now that's
what i do now i'm really going to try
and
stick with this as i try to figure
myself out
for the first time i guess in my life um
oh and also uh how about that uh motogp
race
congratulations to uh fabio cuatro
um winning the race it would have been
more exciting if alex rinse and
uh zarco didn't [ __ ] wipe out towards
the end that kind of killed some of the
drama
uh of the race but it also
also built it because it kind of like
lit a fire under both of them
that now i feel like that they're really
going to have to try to go for some
points
obviously getting no points on that last
race there
and i think fabio cuatro is in the lead
for the championship and mark marquez it
was back congratulations uh he was in
ninth for most of the race those two
guys wiped out he ended up finish
finishing seventh
i just thought he was gonna just come
out and do what he always did
or at least be on the podium and uh
really just shows you how difficult
racing is
that you can't just come right back you
got to like get the rust
you know shake the rust off and then
they got to get his bike dialed in
but um i'm
looking forward to him in a couple of
races getting back to where he was
and then everybody having to deal with
him being a force again and then that's
when the season should get crazy
because i don't think that like uh
mirs rinse cuatro i don't think any of
them
fear that guy i know they respect him
but it's just like good come back and be
as good as you ever were and i'm gonna
[ __ ] beat you because
i mean that's how you wanna win right
you wanna [ __ ] um
you want to beat the best so
anyway i uh so that's my new thing i i
don't know that i'm even going to come
uh jumping back to just being sober here
i don't know if i'm going to go back to
cigars i probably will
but this i have this urge here in the
morning to just slowly give away
everything in my humor door to my
friends who uh who smoke cigars and just
kind of like
like i always kind of want it to be like
uh i got to stop accepting cigars is
what i have to do
um because people give them to you then
you stick them in the humidor and it's
like oh my god it's getting filled up i
need to smoke a few of these but
i think i could i would be way better
off is if i had no cigars at home
and occasionally every other month or
something if i went out
you know with my wife like we hang out
have these great days
you know we'll get a babysitter or
something we just spend like afternoons
together
and i always thought it would be cool to
just kind of go out get something nice
to eat
and then uh you know
going to someplace that has cigars and
some booze whatever wife could get a
drink i could sit there and smoke a
little shorty there
and then head home right and then
that'll be it
that's it and you know my mother always
said everything in moderate everything
in moderation
um all right let's read some advertising
here for
the week uh what do we got here oh look
who it is everybody it's old
zip
are you hiring for spring how did you
hear about us can you give us a home
phone number sorry
are you hiring for spring what type of
role are you hiring for
maybe you need to hire someone to wear
many hats which can be challenging
or you might have a simple position to
fill but it's taking forever
to find someone who's great a great fit
for your company time is money
you know you don't got time for that
[ __ ] that's where zip recruiter comes in
with zip
uh zip recruiter can help you find
qualified candidates
fast and now you can try it for free
free
at ziprecruiter.com burr
c-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r
dot com slash bur whether you need to
hire a civil engineer in new york
a pediatric nurse in nebraska an
attorney and
an attorney an attorney i thought it was
a
attorney an attorney an attorney
an attorney in colorado or even a mascot
in missouri i know the rule if it's a
with another vial you use the end but
just that sounded weird to me
but uh attorney sounds stupid as [ __ ] an
attorney in colorado
oh zip
matching technology finds people with
the right experience for your job and
actively invites them to
to apply so this is great you know you
sign up
people who need a job sign up and you
guys meet it's like a dating
uh dating app for jobs it's so effective
that four to five
employees who post on zip get a
qualified candidate within the first
date
um from accountant
to zoologist jesus christ they're
running the gamut and everything in
between
they got warlord in there
makes hiring easy and right now you can
try it for free
at our only at our only our listeners
get in
link uh ziprecruiter.com if you go to
ziprecruiter.com
today to try zip recruiter for free we
get credit for sending you once again
that zip
dot com slash burst spell out bur b u r
r i think i need to spell out recruiter
r e c r u i t e
r you did not make it to the finals of
the spelling bee
all right oh did they stop doing that by
the way the national spelling bee
because of covid
all these [ __ ] nerds just sitting
there staring out the window spelling
words
with no crowd to do it in front of
that's really sad all right
candid we thought it'd be funny
for those who don't know i'm doing joe
piscopo who used to do alan funt
from the candy camera show we thought
it'd be funny candid
unhappy with your smile you don't have
to be thousands of people have used
candid the clear comfortable removable
and practically
invisible aligners to help straighten
their teeth and now they
love their smile i mean come on man how
can you go through life not loving your
smile
you're literally denying yourself
happiness oh i'd really love to smile
about that but i don't like the way i
look
do something about it just like cameron
s
nashville tennessee once i started
kidding
wait my life completely changed i
started going to the gym more
started eating better only had nine
slices of bacon instead of
76. i even have better dental hygiene
and my my family's like what are you
some sort of
liberal yankee i'm like no i just got my
teeth straightened my goal
for my wedding was perfect teeth and
candy got me there
and canada is here to help straighten
your teeth so you can fall in love with
your smile too and if you fall in love
with your smile if you love yourself i'm
telling you
the broads are going to be coming out of
the woodwork ladies you're going to be
slapping them
[ __ ] you know what's away your
treatment is prescribed and closely
monitored
remotely by a licensed orthodontist
who's an expert in tooth
movement hey big boy what do you do
i'm an expert in tooth movement
okay what does that pay uh you'll have
the same quality of care you'd get
from an in-office orthodontist from the
comfort and convenience of your own home
and while other companies
gross use general dentists
general dentists they're not going to
try to straighten your tooth they want
to yank it out of your head
can it only works with orthodontist well
can it
with candid we thought it'd be funny the
same orthodontist who created your plan
is with you from start to finish like
john calipari
so you never have to wonder how you're
doing
he's going to get your teeth in the
league within one year
um the average candidate treatment is
candid treatment sorry is just
six months you'll start seeing results
way before then and it costs
thousands less than traditional braces
i'll tell you right now i did something
like this
i i did a different system um
but i immediately saw results my teeth
up top were always great but down low
you know there was a little bit of
crowded elevator down there and they
straightened them out and it's [ __ ]
awesome you got to do it
you feel great you start laughing
you know look at my straight teeth
anyway become your best you
start straighting you're straightening
your teeth today right now you can say
you can't have crooked teeth in 2021
that's like having a boil on your neck
was it the [ __ ] 1700s you live under
a bridge there
um oh
my recorder died just like that jesus
christ the middle middle of a reed
i'm being candid it's all right
i just went in the other room played
drums for a half hour let this thing
charge up you know
[ __ ] good times good times you don't
waste a second of the day
being calm and relaxed in dealing with
your past you just continue to plow
forward
um where the hell was i all right well
other companies use general dentists who
just want to yank the [ __ ] teeth out
of your head candid
only works with orthodontist with
candidate well candid
sorry the same orthodontist who created
your plan
is with you from start to finish and
you'll never have to wonder
how you're doing the average candid
treatment is six months i said all of
this [ __ ]
you'll see that uh you'll start seeing
results way before then and it costs
thousands less than traditional braces
uh become your best you
start straightening your teeth today
start laughing at jokes
right enjoy your teeth right now you can
save 75
dollars on candid starter kit go to
candidco.com
burr and use the code bird that's candid
co charlie
oscar.com b-u-r-r take advantage of this
limited time offer to save 75
dollars off 75 dollars those my daughter
says 75
bucks 75 on your starter kit
candidco.com code
burr and least no i don't know we got a
couple more here
simply safe everybody
this is what everyone which is part of
which part of your house feels a little
less secure
uh than you might want uh maybe your
first floor windows
maybe a french door oh jesus
we still giving him [ __ ] for rolling
over to the germans i mean they were
right there
the germans lived in canada and they
came down to america with those [ __ ]
tanks with porsche engines oh yeah we'd
be uh you know
we'd all be eating strudel uh for me it
used to be
um i'm not telling you the weakest part
of my [ __ ] house uh i i'll tell you
the weakest part of my house the fact
that i'm there to defend it
just take whatever you want just don't
break it okay jesus christ um
but i never have to worry about that now
because of my security system from
simply safe now there is no time
day or night where i have to worry
because i know my house is always
being guarded if even if you already
feel safe
that might not be true of everyone in
your your home if you
if you never had a conversation about
that it's honestly not a bad idea to do
it feels really good to be able to press
the home button
on simply save keyboard pad a keypad and
hear the bass say
alarm on and know that if anyone did try
to come in the alarm would go off and
the thing is simply safe
just makes it easy it takes only about
two minutes to customize the system on
your their website
simply safe dot com slash bur
s-i-m-p-l-i
s-a-f-e dot com slash burr this system
arrives in about seven days and then it
takes just about 30 minutes to set it up
all right i've done it myself it's
really easy go to simplysafe.com to
customize your system
and get a free security system and you
also get a 60-day risk-free trial so
there's nothing to lose that's
simplysafe.comburr
you know in the future that'll be hooked
up to a robot you know
and it'll just be like someone's coming
into the house and then
you have to hope that your home security
robot
is smarter quicker stronger and faster
than the criminals
breaking robot you know come in with a
metal head but still wears that black
ski stocking you know because the
burglar has a sense of humor
or maybe he's just nostalgic um
my bookie dude is there anything better
than breaking
into a house when somebody has sleep
apnea i mean if you [ __ ]
cut open a safe they don't even they
don't even hear you uh my bookie
watching any sport is a hell of a lot
more exciting when you got a little at
stake
in the gate but regardless of why you
play you need a platform that makes it
easy
at mybookie.ag they make it easy
uh talk about what games you're watching
now who you would bet on last game you
went to favorite sport etc
uh i've been watching the hockey i've
been watching the hockey and uh i would
bet on the bruins now that they have
taylor hall
yeah i bet the over um whether you're
looking to bet
nba mlb or this weekend's ufc 261
my bookie is the best place to bet and
though odds can change
put a wager on mas vidal right now to
win the fight and you'll triple your
money that's right a hundred dollar
wager on mas vidal
uh would net you 300 bucks in return i
hope i'm saying his name right because i
think that's the guy who came running
out with the flying knee and gave him
the o right there fred
with ufc 261 slated to be the first
full capacity live event get the [ __ ]
out of here since the pandemic began
oh i'm ordering that my bookie should
put up an over under
on how many cases of covid will come out
of it ah
i thought we cured it no matter what if
you're going to bet
there's only one place to do it and
that's my book you sign up now
with promo code burr at mybookie.ag to
get your first deposit
deposit matched up to one thousand
dollars that's promo code bur b-u-r-r
at mybookie.ag to get a free deposit
bonus and start your day off with the
win
bet anytime bet anything anytime
anywhere with my bookie
why don't they just have them fight
outside you know
and just tell people to wear a mask and
most people will and you can limit the
damage
um who knew anyways all right um
ah [ __ ] i forgot to my dad drew you
i forgot to tell andrew i couldn't for
some reason in the he sent me the thing
i couldn't see the picture
i'm going to text him right now because
i want to see this hold on a second
somebody takes the time to draw old
freckles
with leftover paint i'm sure all right
andrew
[Music]
i couldn't see the picture that that
dude's dad drew of me can you text it to
me
question mark yo you always have to have
good punctuation in your voice text
um all right i'll get back to that one
um well anyway i'll just read it here so
my dad is a big fan
of you so as i he actually was
oh so am i he actually was the one
to show me your specials dude if i hear
one more story like this coming from
mexico i think old freckles is gonna
have to go down there and do a little
[ __ ] comedy club
um and he is a big fan of star wars too
so when i showed him the mandalorian and
saw you he got excited and quickly
drew you in your star wars character how
[ __ ] cool is that
and there it is i didn't see it i gotta
i gotta look at it now watch probably a
joke picture
uh really nice acting in the show
sincerely from mexico
well you know what i just watched this
whole thing last night
um i got into uh
i was watching this whole thing on julio
caesar chavez
i that that was the entire time when i
was trying to make it as a comedian and
i missed so much of his career
and my god i watched this whole [ __ ]
thing on him
the body blows the way that guy would
just he would just
break you just watching
i never saw a guy go to the [ __ ]
liver so
fast after a head shot just watching
this entire compilation
and the guy's like career record was
like 147
six and something i i got to get this
right
um as everybody claims to be the grey's
uh
let's see here i mean just having that
many
fights 107
6 and 2.
what the [ __ ] unbelievable
so he's the bar if you ever wondered why
mexican fighters are so goddamn tough
and don't quit
it's because they got to live up to that
guy incredible incredible story
um all right easter bunny is all about
[ __ ]
okay here we go this guy this person is
going for big air early
hey billy mcvegan titty
last monday you asked what the easter
bunny has to do with easter well i used
to go
down a rabbit hole myself pun intended
by a uh i went down a rabbit hole myself
pun intended by a guy named william
cooper
who was a conspiracy theorist
he ran a radio podcast called the hour
of the time
and in a few episodes he broke down the
symbolisms of holidays like easter and
christmas
easter is based off a pagan deity
named oester the catholic
church just ripped off everything from
the pagans and is all about
fertility and rebirth it corresponds
with spring
everything has life again
born again which is why they threw
christ coming back from the dead
on top of that after the romans became
catholic
but the easter bunny is all about
[ __ ] and having babies yes he guys
he's not coming back the guy i'm telling
you this is just all
it's a marketing plan but the easter
because this guy just told me this and i
100 this makes way more [ __ ] sense
than this [ __ ]
somebody dying and coming back from the
dead but the easter bunny is all about
[ __ ] and having babies being fruitful
the chicks are obviously about babies
being born
but it's all about the sun's return to a
particular spot in the sky
the vernal equinox google that [ __ ] but
say hello
to noah and kiss the kids whatever that
means
noah's ark love the the podcast and
please for the love of oster and
baby jesus go [ __ ] yourself well here's
my question
what about people in the southern
hemisphere when it's spring up here it's
going into fall down there
so then do they when is there easter
it's the same time right
what do they have a different jesus
um you know what it was as they did it
way back in the time
they didn't give a [ __ ] about the
southern hemisphere they were just in
rome is that's probably the
explanation for it travel right all
right yoga douche
recommended reading and recipes that's
what i'm trying to be although i kind of
fell off of my yoga i need to get back
to it just
find my center my chi alright hi bill
hi bill my husband loves your podcast
i've earned i've heard that you're doing
yoga and meditation now trying i'm
trying to
my husband also thinks yoga is for
douchebags you know what i like your
husband
and i agree with him but he has seen how
much it's helped me deal with my
depression and chronic pain
i was in a really bad car accident six
years ago oh man sorry to hear that
i was lucky enough to have a great yoga
teacher who taught me belly breathing
or pranayama
it helps calm the nervous system and
deal with anger
oh [ __ ] okay i think i need to learn how
to do the old pranayama there
yoga isn't really about stretching not
jesus
don't you love that when you're [ __ ]
30 years into doing it um
not 30 20 something years it's about
exploring your inner self and healing i
thought it was about trying to be more
stretchy than the person next to you on
the mat
that was competition um i think you
would benefit
a lot from this practice breathe in
fresh air
slash life exhale the anger
relax your face let go of the tension in
your shoulder and jaw
rebalance your body and mind i recommend
exploring the wisdom of yoga by stephen
cope
s-t-e-p-h-e-n-c-o-p-e i'm reading all of
this stuff because as much as a lot of
you guys are gonna give me [ __ ] about
this there's a bunch of you guys quietly
being like i'm gonna [ __ ] do that
[ __ ]
um kind of like when i used to drive a
prius everybody's like dude what do you
[ __ ] did you have to blow the
salesman to get that
all right and then secretly be like does
that thing really do good on gas
anyway it will help you understand more
about your visible visual
visualizations with when meditating a
bit of a hard read but you get an idea
of what's happening in your practice
you gotta love a difficult read on on
[ __ ] meditation
uh whenever i feel anxious at night i
take my time to practice this takes me
away
from torturing my husband with my
anxiety i feel a lot clearer after
i also think you should try costco's
frozen
stir-fry veggies they're already sliced
you just add them to your stir-fry
protein
cover with sauce let the veggies cook
till tender frozen veggies have fewer
pesticides than fresh
who knew also try making a stir-fry
sauce beforehand
and storing it so it's quicker when you
cook
my sauce is a third a cup of soy sauce
tablespoon
teaspoon of sesame oil teaspoon of brown
sugar
teaspoon of grated ginger
teaspoon of minced garlic and a third a
cup of water it's good for any type of
stir-fry the ginger and garlic help
fight
inflammation uh happy stretching go [ __ ]
yourself because my husband said
you have to end it that way best oh
thank you very much
i appreciate it um i'm definitely gonna
say that i'm gonna try that hopefully i
do it all right
porn addicted 23 year old oh gee
hey bill no chill i'm a 23 year old guy
from norway and i'm going to get
straight to the point
like many guy out there i've been
transfixed by porn ever since i found
this curse
i love that you called it a curse when i
was a little kid ever since i've been
watching it once a day and sometimes
even
more until a couple months ago where i
figured out that i was addicted to it my
addiction is not
nearly as bad as other people it seemed
but i noticed i was addicted
nevertheless
in my case my addiction was that i
needed to watch it to masturbate oh
jesus
i've been there don't get me wrong i
could still do little wank with my
imagination
however i didn't prefer it now i've been
almost 30 days free and i feel great
about it that's awesome i still get the
urge though
but managed to beat it off pun intended
that was like the pun week
granted it's not as hard as quitting
smoking i can imagine
uh you mentioned a couple times that you
stopped watching porn a while ago
no but then i relapsed i've been i've
been doing it again so i got to stop
again
so i just i went from may to december
and now since december i on and off you
know the holidays are rough everybody
every once in a while you got to turn to
porn to try to take the edge off so i
was just wondering what
made you quit and do you think porn
addiction is something we should take
seriously
absolutely i think we're all lab rats
social media
um uh porn and all of that stuff
and i think the powers that run social
media in porn
will then do what the cigarette
companies do when the studies come out
that say these things are bad and
they're not good for you
they'll they will flood the market with
air quote doctors saying that it's
healthy
that it's not that bad blah blah blah
that's what always happens
um no it's terrible and the people that
are in it were abused as kids
you know nobody with options [ __ ]
gets into that thing it's a terrible
[ __ ] thing and you're actually
helping it out you know
so it's be one less thing that human
beings do to hurt other human beings
that you could get away from
if you choose to while i say this
sitting here wearing clothes that were
made by crying people in sweatshops that
try to kill themselves but can't because
there's nets outside to prevent them
from
plunging to their death all right
husband slash wife argument over the
hole in the ground
literally dear back on the road bill
wife and i agreed we both wanted a
basketball hoop in our driveway
and eventually decided on an in-ground
one
uh being that i am the resident
basketball
expert in the house i played in high
school i decided where
it should go on the driveway uh
she did give her opinion but i used the
scientific meth
method i measured the exact length of
the driveway oh you went in
to find the exact mid i was thinking my
dad put one up
he thought the regulation was nine feet
so we had a nine foot rim he built it
himself bought the hoop
it was actually cool but like it was on
a ridiculous like probably like a
a 20 to 25 degree bank
[Laughter]
you know it was probably eight and a
half feet if you were on the left side
and it was about nine and a half feet on
the right side but it was fun as [ __ ]
um anyway he said wife and i agreed we
both wanted to
wanted a basketball hoop bubble bubble i
measure the exact length of the driveway
to find the exact midpoint
so as to have an equal space on both
sides of the rim
for shooting just like the pros do
that's great
we have a six foot uh we have a six feet
overhang
above our garage which shortens the
court
on that end so i moved the hole about 10
inches away from the side to increase
the area
over there to shoot uh we'll have also
that probably messed with the symmetry
that she didn't like
with the house right well after breaking
my back digging the hole the wife says
that she
she don't like it that is too close to
the road and that the ball will go out
to the street too much
we are now on the fourth day of her not
speaking to me over this issue
oh wow got to that level i woke up today
with the compromise
i filled the damn hole back in of course
of course cause it's all about their
[ __ ] feelings
unbelievable do guys ever win that
[ __ ] fight you can't win if you win
then they just mope around and be a
douche for the rest of time or you give
in
and then they act like that's a [ __ ]
healthy relationship i'm telling you all
of this [ __ ] out there
about how [ __ ] toxic guys are and
they ignore this aspect of [ __ ] women
i swear to god that you are a [ __ ]
prisoner of their [ __ ] emotions
that you have to find your happiness
within
the airspace of their [ __ ] happiness
and they get to [ __ ] do whatever the
[ __ ] they want it's unfucking
sorry this that [ __ ] just sets me up
yeah so of course you filled the [ __ ]
damn hole back in course
you did this is why guys have funnier
[ __ ] stories
you know where's where's her funny so i
pouted and then he gave in and i i
watched
i watched i you know i enjoyed breaking
his spirit
then the guy's got the story of so i'm
[ __ ] filling the [ __ ] goddamn hole
back in it's hilarious
anyways and told her we will order a
portable one
that i can move whenever i want to shoot
all right so you got a little bit back
bill my question is should i have held
the line
being that she knows nothing about
basketball
i am always the compromiser and bridge
builder and normally i'm okay with it
but on this it really bothers me being
her
her lack of understanding or eve on even
uh
ever playing basketball plus her
literally acting like a child and
locking herself in the room
until she got her way in my opinion
really bugs me
how do i kiss and make up on this uh
this is what you have to do
this is what you gotta you gotta play
their game you gotta play the [ __ ]
guilt game so this is what you do
okay you [ __ ] do exactly what the
[ __ ]
she wants you to do and then you tell
her how unhappy it makes you
and then you don't [ __ ] talk to her
you literally play the game back
and be like this is not this is this is
an abusive relationship
that you do this and what's the thing
you can't say in the tone that i'm
saying
you just got to be like fine we'll do it
the way you want to do it
and i just want you to know that this
makes me really unhappy
she's not even going to [ __ ] play
anything you just convey to her
how much pain she's bringing you by
doing this constantly
and then that's what you have to do and
then in the end when she goes uh
i'm sure you can put them a little bit
and now you got to go out and dig the
[ __ ] hole again
all right you have to tell her that we
need to work on this part of the
relationship
all right i'm just going to say it the
way i'd say it to a guy you got to fix
it up for her because this is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right let's just say next time i dig
a hole i ain't putting a [ __ ]
basketball hoop in it you understand
what i'm saying though no don't go that
far but you know what i mean
it's so [ __ ] ridic and i swear to god
that right there
is the normal that right there is normal
with all these [ __ ] stats out there
that all these [ __ ] stupid feminists
are throwing out there just like the
[ __ ] cigarette companies
throwing all of this [ __ ] out to to
support this side of the argument and
acting like they
they want equal footing they don't they
do not
they do not because they completely
ignore this
oh you got me going on a monday um am i
wrong to be jealous of boyfriend using
sex apps and watching porn
no it's it's that's your line
if that's how that makes you feel you
should communicate that to him
and then he should respect that
see see that ladies i'm not always on
the [ __ ] guy's side like
that basketball hoop thing the [ __ ]
dude was right the lady was wrong and on
this one she's right
okay hello from alaska oh wait a minute
alaska what the [ __ ] else is he gonna do
go outside and get eaten by a bear um i
love your podca
monday podcast and enjoy your
straightforward answers i'm 31 years old
and have been with my boyfriend for
about 10 years now
you guys are taking it slow huh recently
he's been downloading all these apps
that are
kind of making me wonder and i guess
feel insecure or uns
or unsure oh he's downloading all these
apps for instance
apps like find more
fish in the sea [ __ ] milfs now
cheaters.com live sex now apps [ __ ]
locals apps
so on and so forth he claims he just
does it to look oh my god
oh god sweetheart sweetheart
what's he gonna download next how to
kill your girlfriend at 10 years
i'm just into true crime and he's not
doing it to
act on anything but still it makes me
mad
am i wrong for feeling this way
absolutely not and he's been with you
for 10 years and he hasn't married you
and now he's looking at this [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] that
[ __ ] that not only are you right to feel
this get out of this relationship
all right um
should i ignore he claims like it's just
like watching porn
but come on [ __ ] locals now uh red flag
or is it just me
looking forward to your response is it a
red flag it's it's the [ __ ] soviet
union
dude i i i don't know what the [ __ ] to t
yeah it's over
it's over okay you're 31 years old
you've still got your life ahead of you
get the [ __ ] out of that thing now
that's a that's a crock of [ __ ]
that's a crock of [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
the easiest question
ever why would you be looking at those
apps
exactly exactly you're looking to
you're looking for a new love baby all
right
the great andrew females just sent me
the picture here we go
let's see here we go
oh my god that's [ __ ] unbelievable
your dad is ridiculously talented
that is incredible i'm gonna have to
post that
that's it i got to do a show in mexico i
mean come on
all right it's it's the one from the
first season
where i got the gun up on my shoulder um
that is legit all right well tell your
dad i said thank you so much thank you
for uh
introducing you to my specials and you
introducing him to the mandalorian
i really appreciate it and uh you know
what one of these years
when this stupid covert thing is over
i'm gonna go to an f1 race or a
uh moto gp race down there and then i'll
do a stand-up show maybe the night
before or something like that
and have a great time uh that means a
lot to me thank you so much for sending
that in
all right okay people that's the podcast
have a great couple of days go [ __ ]
yourselves and i'll check in on you
on thursday
you